>>> NEW ACCOUNT OF THE FORMER
PRESIDENT'S ENCOUNTER WITH COVID
BOLSTERS REPORTING AT THE TIME
THAT HE WAS VERY ILL INDEED IT
COMES FROM HIS FORMER CHIEF OF
STAFF MARK MEADOWS, WHO AS YOU
KNOW HAS A BOOK OUT AND SEEMS A
LOT MORE WILLING TO TALK WHEN A
PUBLISHER IS GIVING HIM SOME
MONEY THAN HE IS WHEN LAWMAKERS
HAND HIM A SUBPOENA.
MEADOWS AS YOU KNOW WAS PART OF
A WHITE HOUSE EFFORT, WHICH
INCLUDED THE PRESIDENT'S
PHYSICIAN SEAN CONLEY TO
PUBLICLY DOWNPLAY THE SEVERITY
OF THE FORMER PRESIDENT'S
ILLNESS.
NOW, AT THE SAME TIME, HE WAS
TRYING TO SURREPTITIOUSLY LEAK
THE OPPOSITE AND WAS EVEN CAUGHT
ON CAMERA, IF YOU REMEMBER,
DOING IT OUTSIDE WALTER REED.
HE AND OTHERS ALSO ACTIVELY CON
S
SEALED THE FACT THAT THE BOSS
TESTED POSITIVE A FEW DAYS
PRIOR, SHORTLY BEFORE
PRESIDENTIAL DEBATE AND SEVERAL
OTHER FUNCTIONS.
NOW, MEADOWS IS TRYING TO
DOWNPLAY THAT AND STAY IN THE
FORMER PRESIDENT'S GOOD GRACES.
HERE'S WHAT HE WRITES ABOUT THE
DAY THE FORMER PRESIDENT WENT
INTO WALTER REED AND JUST AS A
REMINDER, THAT EVENING, DR.
CONLEY PUT OUT A MEMO SAYING
QUOTE I AM HAPPY TO REPORT THAT
THE PRESIDENT IS DOING VERY
WELL.
SO QUOTING NOW FROM MEADOWS'
BOOK, THAT WARNING DR. CONLEY
PULLED ME ASIDE AND DELIVERED
SOME BAD NEWS.
ALTHOUGH THE PRESIDENT'S
CONDITION HAD IMPROVED SLIGHTLY
OVERNIGHT, HIS OXYGEN LEVELS HAD
NOW DIPPED DOWN TO ABOUT 86% AND
COULD BE TRENDING LOWER, A
DANGEROUSLY LOW LEVEL FOR
SOMEONE HIS AGE.
THEN, CAME THE FORMER
PRESIDENT'S SORT OF ODD LIMO
RIDE IN A SEALED CAR AROUND
HOSPITAL GROUNDS IN THE EVENING
AND HIS MASK REMOVING RUETURN T
THE WHITE HOUSE.
WE NOW KNOW BEGAN WITH A
POSITIVE COVID TEST ON THE 26th
OF DECEMBER.
NOW, ACCORDING TO RECENT
ANALYSIS BY "THE WASHINGTON
POST," IN THE SIX DAYS BETWEEN
TESTING POSITIVE AND GOING TO
THE HOSPITAL, THE FORMER
PRESIDENT CAME IN CONTACT WITH
AND, THEREFORE, MAY HAVE
EXPOSED, MORE THAN 500 PEOPLE.
500.
WHICH BRINGS THIS ITEM TO MIND
BY WAY OF CONTRAST.
THEN-CITIZEN TRUMP ATTACKING A
DOCTOR WHO CONTRACTED EBOLA
TREATING PATIENTS IN AFRICA,
THAT RETURNED TO NEW YORK.
WAS HOSPITALIZED.
KEPT IN COMPLETE ISOLATION FOR
THREE WEEKS AND NOT RELEASED
UNTIL HE WAS FREE OF THE VIRUS.
A VIRUS THAT WAS NOT AIRBORNE
THE WAY COVID WAS.
>> I CONSIDER THAT DOCTOR
EXTREMELY SELFISH.
HE WENT ON CROWDED SUBWAYS
DURING RUSH HOUR.
HAD DINNER IN BROOKLYN.
WENT TO A BOWLING ALLEY AND
BOWLED AND WENT ALL OVER THE
PLACE.
I THINK HE IS A VERY SELFISH
PERSON.
>> AGAIN, HE WAS QUARANTINED
ONCE HE TESTED POSITIVE AND NOT
RELEASED UNTIL VIRUS FREE.
HE IS, OF COURSE, DR. CRAIG
SPENCER, DIRECTOR OF GLOBAL
HEALTH AT EMERGENCY MEDICINE AT
NEW YORK PRESBYTERIAN COLUMBIA
UNIVERSITY MEDICAL CENTER AND HE
JOINS US NOW.
DR. SPENCER, APPRECIATE YOU
BEING WITH US.
PUTTING ASIDE THE -- I DON'T
KNOW IF IT'S IRONY OR JUST
ABSURDITY OF THE FORMER
PRESIDENT'S ATTACKS, KNOWING
WHAT YOU KNOW ABOUT THE TIMELINE
OF THE FORMER PRESIDENT'S COVID
TEST, AND HOW SICK HE WAS WHEN
HOSPITALIZED AND "THE WASHINGTON
POST" REPORTING HE MAY HAVE COME
IN CONTACT WITH 500 PEOPLE.
I'M WONDERING WHAT YOUR REACTION
IS?
>> WELL, I SHOULD START BY
SAYING QUITE HONESTLY NONE OF
THESE REVELATIONS ARE A SURPRISE
TO ME.
I AM AN EMERGENCY MEDICINE
DOCTOR.
MY JOB IS TO PUT TOGETHER SMALL
PIECES OF INFORMATION THAT ARE
SAID OR THINGS THAT MIGHT BE
OVERLOOKED OR NOT SAID TO
REALLY, YOU KNOW, MAKE A
DIAGNOSIS.
PUT TOGETHER A STORY.
AND IT WAS VERY CLEAR FROM THOSE
PRESS CONFERENCES LAST YEAR WHEN
THE PRESIDENT WENT TO WALTER
REED THAT HE WAS MUCH SICKER
THAN THEY WERE LEADING ON.
IT WAS CLEAR THAT HE WAS ON
OXYGEN.
IT WAS CLEAR THAT HE WAS A
PATIENT WITH SEVERE COVID.
NOW, GRANTED, THE PRESIDENT --
FORMER PRESIDENT AND I HAVE
DISAGREED ABOUT INFECTIOUS
DISEASE THREATS SINCE AT LEAST
2014.
I HAVE LONG SINCE BEEN
VINDICATED BUT THIS REVELATION
JUST SHOWS THAT IN THOSE DAYS,
THE PRESIDENT WAS DOING WHAT WE
WERE ALL CONCERNED HE MIGHT BE
DOING, WHICH WAS ATTENDING A
SUPERSPREADING EVENT THAT HAD
EMERGED FROM THE WHITE HOUSE AND
WAS PUTTING THE REST THE COUNTRY
AT RISK.
>> HE MET WITH GOLD STAR
FAMILIES.
IT'S REALLY KIND OF INCREDIBLE,
THE LIST OF PEOPLE HE MET WITH.
HOW DANGEROUS IS AN OXYGEN LEVEL
OF 86%?
MEADOWS SAYS THAT'S WHAT THE
FORMER PRESIDENT'S OXYGEN LEVEL
WAS BEFORE HE WAS TAKEN TO
WALTER REED AND THAT'S --
YEAH -- THAT'S HIM GOING TO
WALTER REED I THINK.
>> THAT'S INCREDIBLY DANGEROUS,
ESPECIALLY IN A 73-74-YEAR-OLD
MAN.
YOUR RISK OF DYING AT THAT POINT
IS INCREDIBLY HIGH AND SO WHEN
WE HAVE PATIENTS WHOSE OXYGEN
LEVELS DIP BELOW 90%, THEY WERE
ADMITTED TO THE HOSPITAL.
THEY WERE GIVEN STEROIDS.
THEY WERE OFTEN GIVEN HIGH-FLOW
OXYGEN AND WE TREATED THEM VERY,
VERY CAREFULLY BECAUSE THEIR
RISK OF DECOMPENSATING, OF
GETTING WORSE IN THE FIRST 24 OR
48 HOURS WAS INCREDIBLY HIGH.
AND AGAIN, WE SAW THIS NEARLY
EVERY SINGLE DAY IN MARCH AND
APRIL OF LAST YEAR.
WE SAW THIS THROUGHOUT THE
PANDEMIC.
WE STILL CONTINUE TO SEE PEOPLE
WHO COME IN WITH OXYGENS REALLY
LOW AND ALWAYS TAKE IT SERIOUSLY
BECAUSE THESE PEOPLE GET SICK
REALLY FAST.
>> MEADOWS SAID THE FORMER
PRESIDENT COULDN'T CARRY HIS
BRIEFCASE WHEN HE WALKED OUT TO
MARINE ONE.
THE WEIGHT WAS TOO MUCH FOR HIM.
FROM YOUR EXPERIENCE TREATING
COVID, WHAT OTHER SYMPTOMS WOULD
THE PRESIDENT HAVE BEEN FEELING
AT THAT STAGE OF AN ILLNESS?
I MEAN, WHAT DOES IT FEEL LIKE?
>> WELL, AS SOMEONE WHO'S HAD --
HAD A BAD ILLNESS, IT FEELS
HORRIBLE.
IT FEELS WORSE THAN A BAD FLU.
YOU FEEL INCREDIBLE WEAK.
YOUR FEVER AND THE MALAISE.
YOUR WHOLE BODY ACHES AND IT'S
HARD TO DO VERY BASIC THINGS.
I IMAGINE THAT'S EXACTLY HOW HE
WAS FEELING, ESPECIALLY IF HIS
OXYGEN WAS DIPPING THAT LOW.
YOU DON'T FEEL DESPGREAT.
IT'S HARD TO MUSTER THE ENERGY
TO DO ANYTHING.
>> I WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE
OMICRON VARIANT.
IN A SMALL STUDY USING SAMPLES
FROM 12 PEOPLE, DOCTORS IN SOUTH
AFRICA FOUND THAT PEOPLE WHO
PREVIOUSLY HAD COVID AND
RECEIVED THE PFIZER VACCINE ARE
LIKELY TO BE WELL PROTECTED
AGAINST THE OMICRON VARIANT.
THEY ALSO FOUND THAT PEOPLE WHO
ONLY HAD THE PFIZER VACCINES
WERE AS PROTECTED.
SO, GIVEN ALL THE MUTATIONS THAT
THE VARIANT HAS, DOES THAT
SURPRISE YOU AT ALL?
WHAT DOES IT TELL YOU?
>> WELL I THINK THE FIRST THING
IT TELLS ME IS THAT WE NEED TO
BE ETERNALLY GRATEFUL FOR THE
SCIENTISTS IN SOUTH AFRICA THAT
HAVE BEEN DOING THIS WORK
DESPITE TRAVEL BANS MAKING IT
DIFFICULT TO GET THE REAGENTS
THAT THEY NEED.
BUT LOOK, I DON'T THINK THE
STUDY WAS TOO SURPRISING TO A
LOT OF US WHO HAVE SEEN THE
MUTATIONS ON THE OMICRON
VARIANT, WHO HAVE SUSPECTED THAT
IT WAS GOING TO DECREASE
POTENTIALLY THE PROTECTIVE
EFFECTS OF OUR VACCINES.
BUT REMEMBER --
>> AND SORRY, DOCTOR, BY THE
WAY, I MISSPOKE.
THE PEOPLE WHO JUST HAD THE --
THE PFIZER VACCINE ARE NOT AS --
AS PROTECTED AS PEOPLE WHO HAD
PFIZER AND COVID.
>> RIGHT.
WELL, THIS IS ALSO -- THIS WAS A
LAB STUDY.
THIS WAS IN A DISH.
THIS WAS, YOU KNOW, LOOKING AT
TISSUE FROM 12 PATIENTS SO I
WOULDN'T EXTRAPOLATE IT TOO FAR.
BUT LOOK, WHAT WE KNOW IS THAT
PEOPLE WHO HAD COVID AND GOT
VACCINATED WERE MORE PROTECTED
THAN PEOPLE WHO HAD COVID AND
DIDN'T.
WE KNOW PEOPLE WHO GOT
VACCINATED AND GOT A BOOSTER ARE
GOING TO BE MORE PROTECTED THAN
THOSE WHO HAVEN'T GOT A BOOSTER
OR WHO HAVE NOT BEEN VACCINATED.
SO THE STUDY SHOWS US THAT THE
VACCINES LIKELY ARE STILL GOING
TO WORK.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO GET A BOOSTER
AND EVEN IF YOU HAVE HAD COVID,
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO BE
VACCINATED.
WE KNOW IT'S ALREADY SPREADING
HERE.
DELTA IS OUR PROBLEM RIGHT NO
Y
BUT WE NEED TO MAKE SURE WE ARE
ABLE THAT THWART OFF THIS COMING
WAVE OF OMICRON INFECTIONS AS
WELL.
GETTING VACCINATED.
>> YEAH.
TODAY CDC DIRECTOR DR. ROCHELLE
WALENSKY SAID THE ANIME
CONVENTION, WHICH WAS HELD IN
NEW YORK CITY WILL LIKELY
PROVIDE SOME OF THE EARLIEST
DATA ON TRANSMISSIBILITY OF THE
OMICRON VARIANT IN THE U.S. OF
THE 53,000 PEOPLE WHO ATTENDED,
35,000 HAVE BEEN CONTACTED AND
ENCOURAGED TO GET TESTED.
I MEAN, THERE IS USUALLY NOT
THAT KIND OF LEVEL OF TESTING.
WHAT WILL YOU BE WATCHING FOR
AMONG THIS LARGE GROUP OF
PEOPLE?
>> WELL, WE ARE GOING TO BE
LOOKING TO SEE WHAT THE ATTACK
RATE IS IN PEOPLE WHO WERE
THERE, MEANING WHAT PERCENTAGE
OF PEOPLE WHO GET TESTED TEST
POSITIVE.
AND HOPEFULLY, DO THAT
SEQUENCING TO SEE HOW MUCH OF
THAT IS SOMICRON.
LOOK, THIS WAS HAPPENING AT THE
SAME TIME WE WERE HAVING 90,
100,000 CASES A DAY SO IT WON'T
BE SURPRISING IF SOME PEOPLE
ULTIMATELY TEST POSITIVE.
IT WILL BE UNCLEAR FOR A WHILE
HOW MUCH OF THIS IS OMICRON
SPREAD, HOW MUCH OMICRON IS
LIKELY TO BE MORE OF A
SUPERSPREADING VIRUS THAN DELTA.
ALL INDICATIONS SEEM TO BE THAT
IT IS MORE TRANSMISSIBLE BUT WE
ARE STILL DOING THAT SCIENCE.
THE ANIME CONVENTION, AS WELL AS
ALL THE RESEARCH THAT IS
HAPPENING IN EUR